the best part of backing a Kickstarter
is the stretch goals more promised bang
for your pledged buck the developers of
battalion 1944 are now working on
stretch goals for the upcoming World War
2 game after hitting their target in the
first three days of the campaign I'm
Kate and this is your gamespot news
update we have something awesome in the
works which a lot of you have been
asking for bulkhead set in a Kickstarter
update but you'll have to wait a little
while longer as we want to show you
exactly what it is that we plan to
implement into battalion 1944 to push
the authentic World War 2 experience to
even greater heights with 24 days to go
as of Monday there is still plenty of
time for further funds to come in and
give the game a bigger budget bulkhead
already spent a hundred thousand pounds
or 145 thousand dollars of its own money
to get the game off the ground the
funding goal for battalion 1944 was also
a hundred thousand pounds which had met
after just two days a time of press the
campaign is currently at 173,000 and 500
pounds over one hundred and
seventy-three percent funded with 5820
backers in short battalion 1944 is an
infantry based first-person shooter with
an emphasis on raw skill bulkhead said
no grinding no exosuits just you and
your skill as a player sounds like
something you'd like have you already
backed it on Kickstarter or do you think
making world war two shooters is just
too soon let me know in the comments or
come if I me on Twitter I'm at how not
to draw thanks for watching and for all
your gaming and entertainment news keep
it gamespot